you know i mean like so and it's like
you hear all these and then joe was also
talking about how like in in japan
there's a lot more cases of
children serial killers
where other kids are just killing other
kids just to like see what's up like
what it feels like yeah and they would
take him in the [ __ ] woods and just
kill him and like decapitate them like
crazy [ __ ] bro that's crazy you don't
really hear the us that's insane like if
we heard some [ __ ] like that you know
everyone in the u.s is covering all of
that [ __ ] like you're there's no way no
one's in five four
three
two
one
hello everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain podcast as i
hold this mic like it's a big [ __ ] yeah
oh wow you like that
you like that yeah how would you handle
it if it's a big giant [ __ ] i just
probably walk away
that's very like uh this is a little
much that's self-control no thank you i
need to go i wonder if a girl has ever
looked at a penis that was too big just
like we're not doing this i'm sure it's
happened
yeah i'm sure it's happening i don't
know what that's lying i don't mean
neither i ain't packing like that pat
what is it like
no no i think
the grower or the show i watched the
whole uh bbc documentary bbc yeah
broadcasting
it was a documentary about men's penis
size and they were talking about how
well number one that was the first time
i ever realized that there were growers
and showers you know what that is bro
the documentary the guys that made the
documentary are a bunch of small dick
dudes like me that are trying to justify
while their dicks were small damn i
didn't even talk about what the
documentary was wow yeah yeah yeah yeah
all right all right it's just it's just
a take on it bro
what was the take you didn't hear what
the documentary was about i like to
interrupt people apparently
i'm bad defensively
dude [ __ ] tim always bringing out a
magnifying glass every time we have sex
she's like is it there i can't even see
it's a bit that we have look at his
pimple crotch
but they were doing a test to see like
the different uh
different modalities and how you can
enlarge your penis modalities oh yeah
like so how would you just sell it for a
friend it's like there was creams there
was pumps there was like every type of
thing that people say that you can do to
get your dick bigger like masturbating
frequently or whatever and they were
masturbating frequently don't work by
the way yeah and it hasn't worked for
you at all
i'm a furious but the one that worked
the best was like this cream oh really
it was a cream that worked right how
much did it add
a lot i think it was an average of half
an inch
wow which is actually pretty sad what's
the name of this cream not bad
what's the name of this question
i think the documentary is on netflix i
mean not netflix on youtube you can
watch it on bbc huh but they were just
like yanking at dicks and like showing
they were just pulling on dong
[Music]
and they're showing like uh like showers
and growers and so there was a guy with
a flaccid dick that was like six inches
long damn and then when it got erect it
was still six inches oh they didn't
change yeah so showers apparently
they're
the length of their dick and when it's
erect is the same size wow so it's a
it's real it's not yes
there were like some people whose penis
like it went from like five inches to
six inches like only an inch in growth
but when if the width would get bigger
but it was the same size penis so that's
the difference between a shower and a
grower like
yeah so a grower on average it would be
like a two inch penis that elongates to
about five to six but a shower would
just be six flaccid six hard oh wow
fascinating that was fascinating that he
has no idea i had no idea i thought it
was just like [ __ ] no no no i
thought everybody was a grower
that's why some people are sure yeah not
according to that documentary but i
didn't know i thought shows just got
bigger too i don't know
i don't know i don't know well i'm
pretty sure they do but the average from
what i saw this years ago but the
average like growth that it had was
about like an inch or so so it would be
five inches six inches right or maybe
five inches you know six and a half a
little bit yeah yeah but these other
ones that are like showers are like two
inches to like five or six or whatever
so kind of [ __ ] shocking maybe when i
get in cold water it's crazy how small
my penis can go oh that should be like a
[ __ ] laser battery yeah yeah yeah
yeah the little circles yeah yeah
actually surprisingly small you're the
only one that uses that as a reference
point for penises by the way dude it's
so tiny your dick is as small as the
laser battery i'm like
yeah you're right yeah
it's really small now i think about it
yeah that's very true yeah it's like the
size of an audi belly button
yeah remember those little dinosaurs
they're all small you put them in the
water they grow and they grow mine's the
opposite in water my penis is it gets
down really it just shrinks shrinkage it
shrinks bro ladies and gentlemen
there's something called shrinkage i
hope you ladies understand that oh yeah
hey
i won't let you see me out the shower
bro why not huh cause dude that [ __ ] is
even i laugh at it i look down like
jesus
why is he always laughing every time he
comes out of the shower
oh nick just saw his penis again
you know nick
i laugh like that
like an evil [ __ ] villain oh my belly
and everything dude
did you guys hear about that thing in
philly where the girl who got sexually
assaulted in a subway
i heard about this no oh my god so then
everybody was watching right on a subway
train or subway uh sandwich sandwiches
actually i don't know i think it was a
subway
real question yeah that's a real
question i think it was a subway system
the train yeah it's like the japanese
pornos dude in real life yeah so this
girl apparently got where like straight
up oh
in front of people in the subway nobody
did it and nobody did anything and they
just recorded it
why recorded it they just recorded it go
down but nobody actually intervened and
stopped it so i was like oh my god i
can't wrap my head around this you know
that's well
i heard that's what the story was but i
kind of was like oh maybe it's just i
didn't really pay much attention yeah so
the weird thing is they're saying that
it's like bystander effect right right
you see something go go down and then
you have like this normalcy bias where
you can't almost like compute what's
going on and then it goes into the
responsibility of everybody else around
just like well there's no point in me
calling the cops because they'll call
the cops yeah or if i'm not gonna help
well they'll help they'll help and
everybody just ends up doing nothing
so the the bystander effect started from
this case study
back in new york i forgot the name of
the lady that happened but everything we
learned this is like psychology years
ago she got stabbed right uh yeah she
was getting robbed or stabbed outside of
a new york building and then everybody
watched this go down and nobody called
the cops apparently later on it was
debunked because a couple people did
call the cops but they call that the
bystander effect which essentially what
they said what was happening in the
philly subway station where or the train
where this girl
openly got raped
and nobody did anything so people
recorded this yeah and so i guess like
the defense of that is that it's the new
age way of helping because they're
trying to record it for evidence for the
person to use later yeah instead of
actually intervening and stepping in yes
which is kind of weird but nobody was
like yo bro chill
yeah because she actually got great she
got raped
that's very different like pulled her
pants off type of [ __ ] yeah raped she's
like no stop yeah all right i got you i
got the proof right here yeah part of it
i can understand if it's like on the
street
right because there's a lot of moving
parts but in a subway
it's a very contained space right like
there's a lot of like etiquette that
goes on on a subway like station like in
a subway cart i mean so it is kind of
interesting the fact that like nobody
did anything yeah nothing how many
people were there like there was a
decent amount of people is there a video
that circle circulating [ __ ] i didn't
see the video i i didn't even try to
look at it
like just curiosity of like what other
people were doing or if like they were
acknowledging it like that's the
question is like yeah like what if like
don't do it or stop which apparently
which is interesting uh one of these
articles that i read they showed a
statistic of like how much
men intervene during these like very
like situations versus women and
apparently women step in more than men
do i i think that's which is kind of
weird because like you know when the
idea of oh don't go out by yourself
because you need a guy to help you out
and stop but apparently guys just don't
do anything that's awesome it was like
women can see like you know women can
see what other women go through as far
as like oh this is a weird like some
things don't track with men because it's
not a part of our experience yeah but
rape bro oh yeah
he would have had a phone out for reals
you would have had a light up like
what's happening over there
patrick riley but as far as that context
of somebody seeing something go down and
a woman is the one that's like yo what
the [ __ ] have you ever intervened with
somebody with some [ __ ] going down ever
across the street from i think i told a
story here there was a two homeless
people
fighting across the street it was a man
and a woman and you beat both of them up
yeah you just both had them with the
sweet champ music and i told you this is
your choice
you're okay because you want to be bad
they were fighting in this alley across
the street and it was the girl
fighting like she was socking the dude
out
and then i was like yo like across the
street and i was like at first i was
like what the [ __ ] do i do like i didn't
know what the [ __ ] to do right
and i was like hey you guys good
and he's like yeah just testing all
right
it was because like she was like [ __ ]
with him but she wasn't like like he was
fine like he was
he wasn't like curling up in a ball or
some [ __ ] i think that circumstance
might be different but then he was like
yo man strut [ __ ] me up call the cops
and i was like i'm not gonna call the
cops bro like
i'm not gonna call the cops so i was
like [ __ ] and i was like i was like
standing there for a little bit and it's
starting to escalate so i was like
all right like let me just go over there
so i crossed the street
and i'm like hey you guys got to stop
like someone's going to call the cops on
you guys you guys are going to get
[ __ ] sent to jail like you guys get
[ __ ] with like just stop and she's
like me [ __ ] you like she was taking to
the guy and she was like socking him
like ripping his shirt spitting on him
shoving him and i was like if this dude
sucks this chick i'm gonna have to [ __ ]
this full up yeah
and i was just kind of just standing
there as like referee i was herb dean in
this [ __ ] yeah i was ready to wave it
off
but uh nothing really happened and they
continued to start fighting and [ __ ]
and then
they uh they kind of just
left
what what did he do
i don't know
i've seen their faces around like my
neighborhood so i kind of know who they
are a little i always assess situations
like i've i've definitely been in a
position where i have like intervened
but there's definitely positions where i
just watched it go down yeah like
because i can do nothing there's some
things you just can't like it's out of
your hands and i was like i'm not going
to risk it like i thought the lady the
girl kind of got on my face a little bit
and i was like yo you're about the
cracker
i was going to crack her i was about to
dump her i was about to double egg her
and bieber you know what i mean perfect
and just and just neutralize
neutralizing yeah like
i was out in san gabriel and there was
like this mexican restaurant that bart
introduced me to years ago but i took my
buddy out there
there's this dude like he he was bigger
than me for sure shaved head tatted up
and it was his girlfriend and his
girlfriend's daughter so he's not the
dad but
i forgot what the altercation was but he
was calling her a stupid [ __ ] he was
gonna say he was gonna [ __ ] her up he's
like you better shut the [ __ ] up before
i [ __ ] you up from all these people and
then the daughter was like saying hey
don't curse right sweet little girl and
shut the [ __ ] up tell the little girl to
shut the [ __ ] up and then she looks at
the guy says don't talk to my daughter
that way he goes i'll beat your [ __ ]
ass too if you don't shut your [ __ ]
mouth and then me and my buddy are
sitting across from them right like next
to them like here and we both look at
each other we look up and we go
just continue
like
and people might be like no if i was
there i would have done this
you don't know what the [ __ ] you would
do bro
i could literally draw him
how scary he was thanos he was like
way taller than me just jacked long
[ __ ] navy blue tee all the way to his
[ __ ] ankles yeah like six foot five
tatted up all over his face yeah he kind
of looked like ms-13 [ __ ] and i'm like
no there's no absolutely no way i'm like
sir this is wrong yeah he didn't know
yeah he knows it's wrong right right she
just doesn't give a [ __ ] and at that
point like if he slapped her or like hit
her then i'm sure the circumstances
might have changed of like hey bro can
you not do this right here i'm trying to
enjoy my [ __ ] right now right no yeah i
would have walked outside and called the
cops so he didn't see it it was me and
honestly that's probably the right thing
to do because sometimes you just you
can't help everybody like hello is there
somebody a woman out there ma'am are you
okay i'm not a man
and obviously too like everyone thinks
in their head they're like you know if
that was me i wouldn't no you wouldn't
not if you saw this guy and clearly this
is a real [ __ ] thing if people are
[ __ ] raped on subway trains and no
one's doing anything like it's more
common for people just to be like all
right then in terms of [ __ ] back than
it is to even step and intervene and
sometimes that's not the right thing to
do like you probably shouldn't intervene
all the time like it's very case by case
yeah but i mean though the rape thing is
[ __ ] wow that's very strange there's
a group of other like there's a group of
people on the subway like you could look
around be like yo let's all just tackle
this dude yeah and get him to stop rape
dick is out he's pretty defenseless yeah
yeah dude and also yeah i don't know
that's why i'm just curious the
logistics of everything
of like how it even started happening
and like what other people that's what
i'm most curious about are you trying to
victim blame her is that what you're
saying no i'm talking about other people
by saying like i wonder what their
reaction was you know like i tried to
get him canceled so
i think they're blaming what was she
wearing
what was she about the subway by herself
yeah why was her pants so easy to take
off yeah sure sure she's never heard of
seven belts before you go out ladies
seven
god that's what my mom did
yeah but that is pretty hard to believe
right like you hear this
that is pretty nuts like that doesn't
say anything
i i just um when i heard this story and
i was reading up about it i just kept
imagining what would i have done if that
was happening right
i do believe that i would have said
something or i would have been like what
the [ __ ] yeah you know for sure i'm
almost 100 sure i wouldn't have been
like mr tough guy i've just been like
don't rape yeah i say something i don't
know no rape yeah yeah we decide
yeah bro like i think yeah it's one of
those things too where i'm sure that
like
if somebody took action
then two or three more people wouldn't
be more inclined to do something i think
it's hard because not hard but like
nobody wants to be the first person to
do it especially they don't feel
comfortable this podcast is brought to
you by ship station my friends the
holidays are the most wonderful time of
the year but if you're running an online
store you know they can also be the
craziest time of the year my friends
you've got inventory to manage orders to
fill in a growing list of stressed out
customers checking in twice a day
wondering whether those last minute
gifts will arrive in time with ship
station the hassle of shipping out
holiday orders melts away leaving you
with happier customers and the freedom
to run your business or enjoy so much
needed time off what i love about
shipstation is how it consolidates
everything and it makes my life easier
if you are a business owner or you just
ship things out on the regular if you
don't have something like shipstation
these things take forever it's great
when you have something that gets
everything you need in one place and
that's what shipstation does for my
shipping needs easily import orders from
every sales channel whether it's amazon
ebay etsy or your own website and
automate just about any shipping task
all from one easy to use dashboard
shipstation works with all major
carriers international and local
including fedex uh sps and ups so my
friends you got no worry ship station
has your back so check it out my genius
brain listeners use my offer code
geniusbrain to get a 60 day free trial
just enough time to handle the holiday
rush just go to shipstation.com click on
the microphone at the top and enter code
geniusbrain shipstation make ship happen
in like a very because look let's be
real most people don't feel comfortable
in a very physical situation of course
nobody like because obviously this is
going to be very physical like if if you
try to stop somebody from being raped
this guy's obviously [ __ ] crazy
like what are we doing but it is
i
it's really hard for me to believe that
no one did anything yeah yeah that kind
of makes you lose hope in him yeah but
and then people were like well i was
responding it for evidence it's like
damn i don't think that's the important
part like if you have like 12
eyewitnesses [ __ ] your recording well my
witnesses are saying the same thing
exactly you're pretty much good to go
don't they have cameras in the subway i
think so
yeah that's a bad that's a bad excuse
you know what i mean it's like you said
12 people also just stopped the [ __ ]
from happening
i'm sure she just wanted it to stop you
know
i don't know what that is like is it
because everybody is so used to not
interacting with people like the first
thing they do is grab their phone
because like when [ __ ] goes down now
like i'm always the person that brings
out this phone last because i don't
think about grabbing my phone first me
too yeah so i never have this footage
like this some event happens and i go i
should have recorded that like when
people record whole concert sets yeah um
you didn't experience anything annoying
annoying you're gonna watch us back yeah
yeah like i get it like we're an old
like uh like at disneyland or something
and like old people pull out their phone
and they just like film like stuff like
oh wow look at the rocks in indiana
jones like wow this is very good like i
get that like you're just older i mean
yeah right but the fact that
you're not gonna watch that [ __ ] you're
gonna re-watch the [ __ ] concert set
and it's like dude
you don't have fun there yeah right
there's just like weird [ __ ] going down
like in japan too there was a guy that
who was dressed like the joker this he
killed he stabbed like 17 people what do
you mean there's 17 people yeah we
covered it on jk oh my god that number
was 17.
like nobody did anything he was the guy
he was dressed up as the joker like the
villain to the batman yeah he was just
sitting on the subway just chilling and
out of nowhere decides to go on a
[ __ ] stabbing spree he set something
on fire like he made like a ring of
gasoline or some [ __ ] and that's so
tired of being a virgin
and apparently his rationale was i want
to kill as many people to ensure that i
get the death penalty
that's what the that was his that's what
he was doing crazy thing is go kill
yourself that dude yeah it's
[ __ ] yeah you could just kill yourself
without killing people you could
literally jump off a bridge head first
go straight into some [ __ ] combat and
you'll be fine but they just want to
share the pain
that's what it is it's like they want to
share it dude i was looking into crazy
like weird japanese serial killers i
feel like joe had that conversation
about all these different murderers and
[ __ ] brutal dude dude japanese serial
killers are [ __ ] nuts they take it to
the next they make our syracuse like
[ __ ] yeah what do they do there was a
case where uh well
it was either the jk news article or joe
was mentioning about the uh the guy who
um it was these students who were gang
raping another student for like months
for months and they would take money
from people to let them gang rape this
girl
and the mom of the students knew
like of the dudes of the guy the dudes
rapists of the house they were keeping
this [ __ ] girl in bro
you know i mean like so and it's like
you hear all these and then joe was also
talking about how like in in japan
there's a lot more cases of
children serial killers
where other kids are just killing other
kids just to like see what's what's up
like what it feels like yeah and they
would take him in the [ __ ] woods and
just kill him and like decapitate them
like crazy [ __ ] bro that's crazy you
don't really hear the us that's insane
like if we heard some [ __ ] like that you
know everyone in the u.s is covering all
of that [ __ ] like you're there's no way
no one's gonna hear it like not hear
about it what is that like what do you
why do you think i don't know man i mean
i know they're like a hyper like
emotionally repressed culture like you
don't you don't emote to the outside
world sure right like you keep your
feelings on the inside and then you rate
people on the side or some [ __ ] and you
murder them and take them to a forest
yeah but it's
i i have a feeling i mean we could
probably have to do my own research and
i'm pretty sure a lot of people can but
i'm pretty sure it has to do with the
repressed culture like having to always
keep things inside like when we were in
japan we went to a place called a
monster cafe have you heard of those
it's literally a place where it looks
like
what you would see if you were on
shrooms it's just mushrooms and all
these willy wonka characters and there's
these guys who uh cross-dress and
they're they're your servers wow but
this is like their version of you know
doing things outside the norm because
it's such a strict culture like work
culture is very serious it's very
straightforward but that's why you see
like a lot of these older japanese
businessmen when i was in japan and i've
been like two or three times now where
you go to the bar and these same guys in
the morning who are just very pristine
just straightforward but at the bar
loud as [ __ ]
screaming just joking around having the
time of the life getting drunk till like
4 or 5 a.m in the morning yeah so
i i i'm pretty sure it has to do
something with that like when you tell
somebody to be a certain way you just
[ __ ] crush them down constantly
they're just going to flip out yeah also
too in like korean and japanese culture
there's a lot of shame
so that shame [ __ ] also motivates you to
hide a lot of the [ __ ] that's happening
right so even if your kids like this
psychopath killer they'll pretend to the
rest of the world like everything's okay
and that's probably the phenomenon with
the mother of the kids
uh that were raping this chick
like it in her mind it's [ __ ]
disgusting but but that's that's the
reality it's
her ignoring it yeah she's like i don't
i don't want to make this a real thing
like because once you acknowledge it
then it becomes real right but this four
poor [ __ ] girl was getting gang raped
for like months
you know and just because she didn't
want to like
realize that her son is a [ __ ]
monster did you get her friends
these two [ __ ] guys literally
kidnapped somebody and had this girl
used as like a sex toy for random people
this is that's insane that is [ __ ]
insane it's like one of the most
notorious stories of like
this type of [ __ ] like is this happening
so crazy like how can you believe this
the 2000s like or like what like
recently or a long time ago
that's [ __ ] bananas dude i can't
believe that [ __ ] yeah just even like
the idea of the guy who dressed up as
joker and was like i'm gonna kill as
much people as i can just so i can get
the death penalty it's [ __ ] insane
the guy dressed up as the joker yeah
it is interesting to see how i mean it's
dark but like how different cultures
like
you know what i mean like how it comes
out in different cultures like the
serial killers or the crazy [ __ ] you
know everybody has you know i i think
too like especially when we come to this
country people talk about like our our
our gun murders or whatever what not
it's like that's we'll just wait till we
dig up what some other countries are
going through yeah like everybody has a
dark side to it yeah for sure it's
perfect this happened in 1989 she was
17.
and this is the crime is believed to be
the worst case of juvenile delinquency
in japan that's some [ __ ] juvenile
delinquency for sure i've ever heard
crazy dude
yeah so they they grabbed her off her
bike kidnapped her
brought her to the house
and they believe there's some like
yakuza connections
jesus so that's a whole [ __ ] thing
but yeah dude this story is really
[ __ ] dark that's dark as [ __ ] so
yakuza just runs [ __ ] over there still i
mean it's interesting right there's like
i mean i saw this map recently of
yakuza but the mafia right it was like
in sicily and it kind of denoted by
color what parts like like the sicilian
mafia still ran and it was like 80 of
sicily
so damn like like yakuza they don't
really say it out loud but from what i
heard from other people is that they're
still very prevalent out there sure and
they're businessmen so they run things
out there right yeah right so
there's a reason why people tend to stay
pretty orderly because you're not going
to [ __ ] with the yakuza's money yeah
right right they'll [ __ ] you up like
yeah some serious [ __ ]
a buddy of mine ed was talking about how
even in japan when the the hurricane hit
and ed went over there to go help the
hurricane victims guess who else was
helping yakuza
because it's their area yeah the yakuza
like members are [ __ ] helping rebuild
japan
which is crazy right like [ __ ] houses
funny story too one of our buddies so if
you when you go to in japan and you go
to onsen which is a spa your if you have
tattoos they they usually typically
don't let you in because it denotes that
your yakuza like if you have tattoos
like people just don't get tattoos
willy-nilly in japan
and so
you
so ant our buddy he has a [ __ ] ton of
tattoos and while we're in japan he was
cutting up fruit and he and he cut his
finger so he had a wrapped up so it
looked like he had a yakuza member chop
off his finger so he was in the subway
train everybody was hella far away from
him
with the missing fingers and they're
like yo who the [ __ ] is this guy [ __ ]
with that with his slick back hair and
his dragon tattoos all over his arm and
a missing finger yo yeah that's pretty
crazy doug cause i heard that's i heard
other people that go to japan they say
like
you can't be showing off your sleeves is
that true like you have to cover up your
[ __ ] yeah they don't want you to show
your tattoos and stuff especially at
specific restaurants because it denotes
that you're like in a gang when they
take which is how it used to be here
back in the day too yeah if you had a
tattoo it was some gang [ __ ] yeah now
it's just like you know artwork
el salvador is the same [ __ ] like you
can't be showing off any tattoos like
they'll ask you to like take off your
shirt let me see your tattoos
and they'll make sure that you're not
like ms ms-13 or some [ __ ] oh my god
dude that mess is wild as [ __ ] too dog
tiff trying to bring me to el salvador i
want to go but she's like it's not safe
for you and i'm like then why would you
take me yeah yeah all right then stop
trying to get me
she hasn't her mom wants to take us
[ __ ] wild she looks great but they
were like all right they have so many
rules where i'm like all right i don't
want to go no more they're like all
right you can't wear fancy clothes i'm
not like i wear anything fancy but like
no brands nothing no fancy jewelry
nothing like that denotes that like
you you have money yeah exactly and it's
like i'm like doc
you should just [ __ ] yeah they're gonna
[ __ ] pick me out of a lineup you know
do you it's kind of scary men like even
mexico too
people expose me all the time dude it
was just a shootout in like uh near
cancun like a resort area some some uh
some like americans got killed and [ __ ]
they got they got caught up in a
shootout by some cartel [ __ ] yeah this
shit's wild bro it's not safe anywhere
down there i had this conversation with
somebody recently too where this person
tends to be very negative but
this person just kind of lives in their
own world
and she i think she goes out with a dude
that's mexican right and she's like well
yeah like me and my boyfriend like we're
going to go to oh clearly these mexicans
like we're gonna she wants to move to
like she's like
america's crazy like it's so [ __ ]
nuts here people don't care about each
other she goes i'm saying i think me and
my boyfriend were just going to move to
mexico i was like yeah excuse me yeah
right out of all the places i was like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about what
is she what race is she uh she's white
i'm like listen
you are the prime suspect to get
kidnapped yeah are you [ __ ] insane
but people just seem so much nicer out
there i'm like just because you go to
resort
like that's like cartel land like she's
white
people like what are you talking about
you'll you'll [ __ ] get murdered i
know somebody i don't know somebody this
is uh i told the story in the podcast
before but
there was a girl that went to a church
that i was attending
she
went on a mission trip and she went
missing
and she got caught by the cartel
they took her church had to raise money
to get her back and they wanted a
million [ __ ] dollars from the church
they raised 500 000 they gave her back
but half her body in a barrel
oh like
[ __ ] crate this is by the way wow not
like oh i heard it through a friend this
is when i was in college attending this
church yeah which was [ __ ] nuts and
at the time like i i was a part of like
a bible study group that was part of the
church but i didn't actually go to the
church sure but people were wrecked they
were crying about it i don't know what
was going on because i never met this
girl yeah but that's [ __ ] crazy dude
yeah they don't [ __ ] around they do wild
ass [ __ ]
like that's the thing is people like
america we have our problems but people
don't understand like how good we got it
here dude you go to like i said mexico
even like other countries like they will
[ __ ] your ass up for reals like just
take your organs like oh your wake up
organs are going on what the [ __ ] about
you bro it's crazy because the cops
can't stop the cartel yeah the cartels
run [ __ ] yeah dude cartel
yeah i heard they have like their own uh
they like built their own um cell phone
towers they have like their own cell
phone like their own version of sprint
they can't get hacked into they have
drones they have cameras and cities like
what they run [ __ ] like they have like
like military almost trucks patrolling
cities like they they run [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] that and then there's
like there's like i don't know how many
there are now but they fight amongst
each other that's why i like the
fentanyl [ __ ] a lot of people think it's
because uh one cartel is trying to ruin
like another cartel's supply so they're
putting fentanyl and [ __ ] so americans
die and then they'll even beef with each
other yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh that's [ __ ] crazy
one conglomerate no there's a there's a
few i don't know what they are now but i
think there's a few like at least two
to three it's crazy how much like drugs
run the world like i
i like i'm not we're not part of this
world at all clearly like there's a
crazy diamanta supply for it yeah i am
obviously yeah you got a pot stick on
your hands yeah i got a potstick brush
nick about to bust everybody i i am the
expert on drugs you're about to bring
the whole empire
with your savvy police whatever you guys
want to ask let me know i'll answer it
that's the weird thing though like when
people are on their high horsepower like
they they kind of like oh my god i can't
believe these people are doing this
stuff in mexico for drugs while they
they [ __ ] do fentanyl and all this
other [ __ ] it's like you're the one
they're you're buying their stuff you're
buying it that's you you jackass you're
funding them yeah like what the [ __ ] are
you talking about you're literally fine
i'm glad you look down at people when
you're the person they're supplying like
what the [ __ ] are you saying this
podcast is brought to you by uncommon
goods if you're anything like us you
want to win the best gift ever title
this holiday season listen i know you
guys got a bunch of white elephants and
if not white elephants you guys have a
bunch of little gifts and knickknacks to
gives knickknacks knickknacks to give
your friends and family well guess what
don't be the person that gives crappy
gifts you can give knickknacks but they
better be good and guess what if you go
to uncommon goods my friends the
creative and unique gifts that you can
give out that people will actually love
is going to be there it's saving my ass
this holiday couple of stuff that i
checked out that i'm probably going to
cut for people uh i don't know if i
should you know what i'm going to say
anyways it's this wireless phone charger
pad looks freaking dope i got a couple
of like like whiskey like antique
whiskey glasses that i'm probably gonna
give out to the homies a lot of dope
stuff that they got my friends and trust
me do not be that person that gives out
crappy gifts i hated that person growing
up and i wanted to punch them in their
teeth don't get punched in your teeth
this holiday huh to get 15 off your next
gift go to
uncommongoods.combrain that's
uncommongoods.com
brain for 15 off don't miss out on this
limited time offer uncommon goods
we're all out of the ordinary like
cartel stuff scares the [ __ ] out of me
yeah it's scary that thing gets me more
nervous than cartel [ __ ] the thing is is
they're here too yeah like they're here
especially like
[ __ ] they're all over the u.s there's a
whole i don't know how true this is but
there was like a story well not a story
but more like a conspiracy or like a
thought process of all like the little
fruit uh fruit stands
they're all like part with the cartel or
some [ __ ] in l.a i don't know i don't
know i don't know if this is true or not
but there was you're not talking about
my homie ignacio right like i don't i
i'm just gonna treat them very nicely
and buy their fruit because it's
delicious i think that's why they got
ripe fruit all the time as soon as they
get a supply from the cartel uh cartel's
got the girls ignacio ignacio hey you
know how else do they get year-round
ripe watermelon that's true they've got
no other way they've got the good [ __ ]
they feel like how come their fruits are
always good
good fruit fruit
kind of balancing too it's almost like
bad for your health good for your health
breaking even antioxidants breaking even
boom yeah the hot dog carts in la are
all ms13 [ __ ] that's what i mean
and see you know those videos of people
[ __ ] with the cartel like i'm not
cartel although the fruit stands and the
people selling food i was like i hope
the cartel comes and chops your bodies
up i hope they chop all your bodies up i
don't give a [ __ ] you're a piece of [ __ ]
if you [ __ ] with those people they're
the sweetest people all they want to do
is sell fruit but you're over here
spreading propaganda about drugs i know
that's true but that's how to get the
best fruit
what do you want me to do
you're so funny that's just wild my
house is a hot spot for activity of just
random people so i was walking home from
this chicken place that i like right by
my house and there was a uh uh
what do you call it the ice cream guy
and i walk them behind them and i'm like
oh it's cool i never see a palette the
man on my [ __ ] street
i'm walking behind him i'm about to get
to my door he parks his cart right in
front of my door and i'm like oh
he walks up to my steps by my gate he
starts peeing on your door not at my
door because there's a there's a
separate like entrance after you're
about to buy some ice cream
i low key kind of was like i was like oh
like this guy's nice and he pulls his
stick out he pulls it out
i didn't see i thought that was
disrespectful and i thought he was part
of the cartel so i'm like i'm not gonna
[ __ ] with you um he pees
on my fence like in the bush area
and i'm standing behind him and i'm
waiting to finish because i'm ready to
go in my house
he turns around he goes
pulls his dick in
gets in his cart and moves away
and that was it you were behind him i
was buying him the whole time why he
didn't say you're like yo what the [ __ ]
i mean there's like a gas station right
there he could just pee in the gas
station hey you know what you know i say
though well you gotta go you gotta go i
bet this guy felt so embarrassed and he
was
he peed on your door dude it wasn't on
my door it was in the bush that's the
most disrespectful thing ever dude i was
like this is your home and what are you
going to do about it
yeah and i just was like
have a good day i just walked in and i'm
so passive you're gonna snap dude
you're gonna you're gonna you're gonna
be the joker on the subway what do you
tell this old man this is like mexican
man peeing on my bushes like don't be
like don't be i'm like hey man could you
not piss in my bush i'd be peeing in the
bushes too what do you want me to do oh
this guy's such a pushover dude i
[ __ ] hate this guy so much bro you're
gonna kill somebody you really are he
seemed like a very old nice man i'm not
gonna tell him [ __ ] that's why that's
why when you drive you're like
[ __ ] son of a [ __ ] that's
different though they're sliding
they're sliding on purpose no no no no
no no no dude you know what it is this
is why i promise people that drive okay
you know where you're going just get in
the lane already you know what i mean
like when people are making a left turn
and and then like as they're about to
hit the crosswalk they decide
the lines that are not perforated
when it's a straight [ __ ] line that's
when they decide to get in the way a man
he's on your house that's okay
but somebody drives a little weird and
then you get really bad
your priorities are [ __ ] up i think
this is very fair your priorities are
[ __ ] weird
yeah but it was it's not like it happens
all the time the guy doesn't pee in my
head i'm not saying you had to kick the
guy's ass but you could have been like
yo could you not do it this
hey can you not pee on my stuff have a
nice day
i saw the guy again
and i saw him and i was like i was about
to pull my driveway i was like i'm gonna
save this [ __ ] pee in my house
he didn't kept walking and then you
bought some pilot that's from here
i got the spider-man with the eyes all
like this
shitty blue eyes
yeah yeah bro but what are you gonna do
dude you tell him not to pee on your
house idiot just gonna get my body cut
in half no thank you dude i'm good i'm
gonna [ __ ] you for that you don't know
can you guarantee that i can't do that
i don't know i don't think they would
have done that
you just called pat can you tell him in
mexico
not to do this tell this mexican guy
mexican to stop peeing on my front yard
just goes hey don't pee on his [ __ ] in
english he's like okay
all right he's like my bad dogs sorry
dude
you're such got a cowboy hat on how can
you be a formal amateur mma fighter and
you're such a pushover dude like when a
guy smokes crack on my front steps i
tell him to leave
that's it could you please leave could
you please leave
there was a guy
he was smoking crack he was smoking i've
never seen a crack pipe before that
close spooky and i was like oh it smells
like crack on my on my front steps oh
you know the smell now i do yeah uh and
in the park i used to train my smell
like chemically
i imagine it being chemically very
chemically like it smells like
something's wrong in the air right there
was another guy who was a smoking crack
pipe on my front and i was like hey man
can you not do this here and he's like
he was like you were a [ __ ] wizard or
something dude
he's looking up grandmaster
and he's like
and then he he stumbles and he leaves
and there was another guy who was like i
don't know if he was drunk as a white
boy
face full of acne i don't know if he was
homeless or not but he was kind of
[ __ ] up and he's sitting on my steps
and he's sleeping
and i'm like yo
doesn't wake up i'm like hey yo and he's
like
and i'm like are you okay bro
and he was like
yeah yeah sorry man i'm just having a
moment and i was like can you just not
sit on my steps man and he's like sorry
bro
all right and he gets up he's falling i
had to catch him
i was like you okay bro and you go
i'm just having it i'm just having a
moment and i was like just sit down for
a little bit
and then just leave when you're ready oh
you're such a nice and i went down to
the water bottle
because i thought he was going to kill
me
so i came back out i gave him away he's
not there he was gone i couldn't find
him i was gone for like maybe like 15
seconds i mean you handled that one a
lot better than the the ice cream guy
yeah but dude he was already peeing like
what do you want me to do like just be
like yeah stream he's gonna fall off
it would have been kind of funny you you
know you you have the opportunity you
were in the right to mess with him a
little bit part of me was when he saw me
he [ __ ] his pants for sure
so he's [ __ ] and peeing on your
steps now and i was like oh no you're
pooping here sir you've got this
let me ask you something somebody's
smoking crack on your steps right but
and just doing whatever the [ __ ] they
want in front of your house yeah but
it's a fine ass woman what do you do i
totally [ __ ] leave yeah oh i'll be
like yo can't be smug smoking crack on
my [ __ ] steps bro and she's like but
why i'd be like you're smoking
yeah i was like somebody who's like
somebody really hot to you
my
wife fine in this world your wife is
dead okay well she finally realized that
she's married to you and she killed her
i don't care how hot anybody is halle
berry could be sitting my [ __ ] steps
i'm going to be like miss barry big fan
please stop smoking quack on my steps
really yeah if hallie's unreasonable was
smoking crack on my steps i'd be like
where's the party
you would do that to halle berry
miss barry loved you and swordfish yeah
tits nice love you and drop like three
but please stop someone cracking myself
wow and why are you smoking crack on my
steps and would you want to come in and
have sex with me
yeah
i don't know you gotta get your
priorities straight
oh i'm saying tiff is gone she's not in
the picture yeah no for sure
but like
this lady's smoking crack bro
but it's halle berry
yeah but like dude imagine if i was like
look this is in my mind this is what
happens i go
miss allie berry can you please stop
someone crack on my step and she's very
apologetic and she's very like oh i'm so
sorry no it's just
and then and then i go would you like to
have sex with me and she goes excuse me
and then i get cancelled and then you go
wait wait wait but i have this stapler
she's
yeah that's in my [ __ ] visions yeah
so you don't even give a [ __ ] it was a
guy or girl you treat them all the same
you're equal
equal opportunity there was a homeless
guy sitting on inside of my house you
know where the bench is inside your
house
big dude his name is trevor you know he
told us his name was bill why you got
his name he liked their homies so no he
called he said he was billy joe billy
joe i wic and he was there a week before
when i was at jk and tiff has the
[ __ ] nerve to this guy was like 6'5
bro big homeless dude big white boy
without his mind he lost his mind tiff
goes up to him he's like please can you
please get out of our stuff get out of
our house i'm like yo
don't talk to him don't go up to him and
like yeah could just call the cops at
that point if he's inside of our gate
call the cops
so she didn't call the cops and she was
like i'm gonna call the cops she's like
go ahead i don't care i wake up saturday
morning like clockwork
i'm like i'm about to leave to go to
work and i'm like
yo this [ __ ] there's a
[ __ ] here i was like hey man
you can't be sitting in my house bro get
the [ __ ] out of here and he's like nah
man the lady inside said i can stay here
bro like nah this is my house
and i was like [ __ ] and i was like billy
joe yeah billy joe i was like and so i
get on my car i parked my car i'm like
hey bro you gotta get the [ __ ] out of
here dog
please leave and he's like nah man i
ain't like just saying whatever the [ __ ]
and he's sitting down and i called the
cops and they they were on their way and
he's like
he's like man all these [ __ ]
like i know the room ourselves wallace i
can talk about pulp fiction like this i
saw bloods and all crips i remember that
specifically i've been on video crazy
and i'm just like oh dude this guy's
[ __ ] nuts he's nuts and he's big as
[ __ ] what have been interested like who
is he so i call the cops the guy the cop
that pulls up is one of my clients
and i was like hey what up dude and he
was like yeah i heard your name on the
intercom i'm going to come so he's like
i'm going to come
this way
let me kill this dude
they actually handled it [ __ ]
perfectly like they were [ __ ] really
cool with it they made sure nothing
happened nothing was crazy and he got up
and he got in the car and then they
asked me if we want to press charges and
i was like
like what's gonna happen they're like
they might give him a ticket no they're
gonna give him a ticket but if he uh
doesn't have any warrants out for his
rest we're gonna let him go
and they'll drop him off and i was like
and then i asked tiff and tiffany was
like no it's okay cause she's a little
sweetheart and i'm like all right we
won't press charges so he left they
found him later on the way and he was
being very belligerent to us he was like
me [ __ ] he was getting in my face he was
about to swing him and i was like
staring at him and i was like what dude
what are you gonna do you know but i
knew nothing was gonna happen and then
my my cop client my buddy grabbed him
and he's like you're assaulting me dude
stop assaulting me and he [ __ ] ran
off and like he was wild bro he was big
as [ __ ] and he was he was pretty scary
looking but he dipped out and my cop
buddy saw him later down a lot later in
the day down the street oh [ __ ] and then
the guy was like hey man i'm sorry for
how i acted earlier bro like my name is
trevor
like i didn't mean to he's a bipolar
yeah probably i mean and it's like this
is just mental illness and he probably
does a little drugs too he does a little
skante yes she smokes a little he
probably wants a little broken weed
though
[ __ ] move huh yeah you need a better
you need to move for our rent bro it's
worth it right now that is never worth
it dog it's fine it's not a big deal
that's crazy you're gonna be a serial
killer dude
i'm fine dude i'm perfectly adjusted
okay you think i'm a murder people you
know what that sounds like you know what
that sounds like that sounds like my
friend abe stop trying to therapize me
no that's like sounds like my friend abe
who is clearly the most flamboyant gay
man
and i said hey abe how long
have you known that you were gay and he
goes i am not gay
all right i love [ __ ] i was like abe
that is the gayest thing i've ever heard
that's what you sound like right now
honestly bro you sound like abraham i
have a good relationship with the
homeless people on my blog like you
could not he almost assaulted your wife
and you allowed it to happen
yeah that's true
but tiff shouldn't have been i was like
babe
yeah and i shouldn't have and i'm like
yeah stay your ass inside and her mom
was like yo what the [ __ ] you doing bro
because she was there too but the
homeless guy
the homeless guy that i broke up the
fight with the two late of the they were
like fighting and stuff and the alley
across the street i see this guy
everywhere he goes to my buddy's coffee
shop
car artisans chocolate go check it out
pasadena he goes there all the time he
asks for water or whatever i see him all
over the block and he says what up to me
only what up bro you guys have been
through some [ __ ] yeah he came up he's
been best friends now yeah at the park
at grand park i was leaving i was
training client i leave and as i'm
walking out he's like hey man what's up
bro and i was like what's up dude he
goes i mean i just want to say like i
respect you i do it for the people damn
you got respect from that respect from
the homies dude bro shut the [ __ ] up
dude get the [ __ ] away from me i mean i
really respect i really respect you man
like you're really cool and your online
training programs are like so good yeah
thanks dude that's not what he said at
all
at all i think you're buying some trash
looking pretty right he's like you've
been working on this kind of like [ __ ]
your wife every now and then yeah she's
great too and i'm like yeah dude tips
great that was cool man you bonded it
was real cool nice nice you have a
really high threshold for just just bad
things you know what it is though is
tiff bro that's what it is this podcast
is brought to you by stance my friends
remember every freaking holiday when
relatives would give you clothing or
socks or whatever that you would never
wear well guess what screw them huh they
didn't get you anything from stance i
love stance socks they got so many
different designs i'm talking about the
office i'm talking about wu tang jill
perkins disney barbie
marvel bob marley major league baseball
and the best thing about this stuff not
only does it look [ __ ] dope
it feels even better all my socks be
stand socks on me stan socks stance
boxers you you best believe it and i've
heard about stans for a long time and
i've had their stuff for actually quite
a while even before the sponsorship so
kidsmith it's fate my friends that they
knew that i'd be [ __ ] with their
socks heavy so they're like i [ __ ]
with genius brain podcast but listen for
the holidays get yourself some stance
socks you know you try to keep them toes
warm you don't try to keep them booty
nice and soft with them silky ass
underwears and guess what all i gots is
stan socks and stance underwears dance
has the perfect gift for every punk and
poet on your list go see for yourself
it's easy just head on over to
stance.com and pick out some styles you
think they might like enjoy the color
and comfort of a life less ordinary with
stance my friends
because she's a social worker
this [ __ ] has empathy for
everybody dog and she's like
i'm over here just slapping the [ __ ] out
of people outside of gyms i know yeah i
assaulted you bro like none of these
people attacked me i just i just i just
talked to him like hey bro can you just
not do that here
and they're like that's reasonable
and they they even the guy that was he
saw me as a wizard who was smoking crack
on my steps was like yeah you're right i
shouldn't be here and he laughed at the
wizards right got a girl there's one guy
i had a guitar this old white dude i see
him all the time too this motherfucker's
like he put all his [ __ ] out and was
organizing it and i was like hey bro can
you just not do this here and he goes
i'm sorry man i didn't know someone
lived here i was like yeah this is my
place and i was like what's your name
he's like tom and i was like i'm nick
bro nice to meet you and i was like yeah
can you just not do that and he's like
sorry man never came back again except
the one time
somebody else camped out this other
homeless dude who is a troublemaker in
the neighborhood this [ __ ]
camped out in front with a tent bro
people on your front
where the sidewalk is oh camp that over
there and then homie with the [ __ ]
ponytail white boy that i told not just
come kick it over here had a guitar
they're [ __ ] kicking it they're like
they're lounging they're hanging out in
front of my house i can hear them inside
like we're watching [ __ ] the office
and i hear these guys talking outside
they're going to camp fire yeah bro so
we had to call the [ __ ] cops and they
cleared them out and it was not a big
deal what is what it is [ __ ] move you
dumbass
is good bro where else am i going to
live with this good of rent what's your
right to rent 2200 bro dude south pass i
paid 23.50 two bedroom dog there are so
many places you got a washer dryer yeah
yeah you got two parking spaces yeah
that's pretty common bro we got three
bedrooms
you don't need three bedrooms you don't
need no you're you're in timber mary you
sleep in one bedroom
park outside where you talk to a
homeless people for fun you [ __ ]
loser i therapize them right now if you
want more community
dude you can get it next year you are
going to [ __ ] move yeah we're looking
we're looking bro you are not looking we
are going to start i'm going to start
sending you places and you are going to
[ __ ] looking for a house
oh really yeah oh really in
aspiria
experience
i saw a lot of places like 1900 2 000
for two bedroom you don't need people
smoking crack on your steps
you you don't get one person smoking
crackers no absolutely
you're in a hot spot for homeless crazy
[ __ ] you're next to the the the gas
station
stop telling people where i lived i
didn't i'm just saying yeah
someone docks your ass just so you have
to move that gas station is fire bro and
then there's guys there that love me
train station he's just like why don't
you move
i don't live here please give me
listings
i only work here you need to move yeah
you know one of the guys that works at
that gas station he's on call customer
service while he's working this the gas
station wow he's like i hear him say can
you please hold
for like games or something 25 50 and
i'll be like okay cool thank you and
then whatever and he goes back and he's
like yeah how can i help you like i've
heard him on a call before wow he's just
hustling hustling bro you don't need to
live there anymore
you 100 do not leave to live there don't
let's have here listen to this podcast
because she's going to be like see i
told you i'm actually going to message
her tonight and just tell her to move
you guys shouldn't move move just pass
that pass is [ __ ] nice yeah all right
bro all right we'll see yeah just go to
southpaw you're there most of the time
anyways yeah
we'll see dude we'll see i'm gonna send
you places after this i'm gonna look
some places up and send them to
tiff is dealing with homeless crazy
[ __ ] she anything is better right now
don't deal with them i deal with them
bro and she brought you back is like
she's like like i want to leave on a
move and i'm like yeah but it's
it's not that bad
it is pretty [ __ ] bad dude that's
terrible you literally had people camp
out in front of your [ __ ] place going
by yeah smoking crackers
[ __ ] red dead redemption campfire
and i'm like babe that's just billy joe
is fine and trevor they're chilling like
i was in glendale with like the most
aggressive armenians i lasted their
[ __ ] 10 months
yeah your threshold for [ __ ] very
low though yeah i don't well i'm paying
for the place yeah right i pay good room
bro our rent are our landlords very good
they fix everything they have a handyman
named miguel one time i texted miguel an
accident and i thought i was texting
tiff
and then i was saying like yo miguel's
the [ __ ] i [ __ ] love this dude i sent
it to him
and then he started laughing like oh ha
ha and i was like my bad dude that was
the wrong text message he's like well
you trying to hook up later or what he's
like you trying to [ __ ] and we [ __ ]
sealed the deal no
more reason for you to leave now now
things are just awkward now miguel comes
all the time bro yeah so the roof in
your office is like this huh it's like
this built like that i thought miguel
fixes
pretty good it's like
like collecting water my air
conditioning has been broken for like
three months it doesn't work you need to
[ __ ] move once i email them to fix it
they're gonna come and fix it there's a
guy with a school bus in the back right
isn't there at school what does the
[ __ ] go to school bus that you
also have impostor syndrome where you
feel oh my god
do you just want to live like this
because it reminds you to stay humble
is that what it is no i like it bro i'm
pretty easy going dude i'm pretty chill
you're a pretty chill
is that before or after like during the
summer time where you sweat your ass off
in that little office dying
yeah that's true i don't know that
office is hot that [ __ ] gets hot but
also though like i don't really spend
all months and the winners i'm in the
office boy i'm in the office but in the
summertime i'm still swimming like this
bro
honestly you really don't you really
don't have to live like oh my god
i promise we're looking like we're gonna
give you literally a few months to move
out if you don't move out
cause look i'm trying to
rent is so cheap i'm just trying to save
money right now your boy trying to save
money because me and tiff are thinking
about trying to buy a house in the next
year or so oh nice we're gonna attempt
to
but let me see i'm looking on zillow
right now let's see what we can find
okay watch literally we'll find a place
right now trust me
tiffany look she gets email updates dog
no one's more thorough for house hunting
and apartment rentals dude a one bedroom
you could you guys could save so much if
you wanted to really save one bedroom
but okay fine two bedrooms
you want us to kill each other
dude what color
there's a living room and [ __ ] what do
you mean
but all right if you want two-bedroom i
just don't understand you
you and alex are the same person bro i'm
not alex brother that [ __ ] lives
in a room dog this what does he live in
a room that dude lives in there
seventeen
roof with like maybe two walls he
doesn't have a real wall
a guy could put his hand through the
title let's just walk through like the
kool-aid man trust me i got it in the
second house
barely
they're pretty thin but i got walls
barely dude i'm gonna find you a new
place the homeless people aren't that
bad i promise you i knock on wood i go
home today it's gonna be a homeless dude
i have to [ __ ] deal with but the cops
are very cool
in my neighborhood you're disgusting i
am and you are not a man and you are not
a man well i'll be i'll be handling yeah
this is like a man dude you're a
[ __ ] lesbian dog
i've known him my whole life the
opposite i've known my whole life so you
were lesbos well guys this wraps up this
[ __ ] disappointing episode of jesus
christ
[ __ ] just a [ __ ] intervention you
jackass from your [ __ ] place i will
bro
okay i didn't know it was that bad i
thought i was like one homeless person
i got a lot of stories okay how many
people have smoked crack on your
doorstep at least three that's a lot
that's a lot i've never had somebody
smoke
comment down below how many people have
smoke cracked on your doorstep and then
you guys will be amazed at the numbers
that my mother does every morning
family does not count it has to be
complete strangers
what is wrong with you man
do better there's this one homeless guy
that i'm really cool with though what's
his name
uh actually i don't know his name but
like he take he he lives a couple blocks
over and he he just [ __ ] he says good
morning to me every day he's a [ __ ]
very nice guy that's just a regular dude
man i'm talking about the guys over here
threatening your life yeah like the lady
decides that i could stay here yeah
that's my wife you know what tim goes
she goes that guy he was like he was
really big he was gonna like he could
have beat you up and i was like man i
want to [ __ ] that full up dog oh
oh wow is that before after you gave him
your bank account number
you [ __ ] pushover no i sent him money
every month
you know it's i respect you
that's a different guy that's a
different guy i like to fit the party
out on the front though that's [ __ ]
funny like guy with a fiddle
they're making s'mores and she's just
really bad at the time
it's like a homeless dude dancing
good evening me lord would you like to
partake in the festivities
so bro
i was like why thank you and i sat down
and i drank with them that's true i want
to drink with you guys while drinking
with them you're [ __ ] ridiculous
well guys we're not friends
you could find nick somewhere dead in a
ditch
dude nick
you could find patrick at patrick.t dot
riley yeah everywhere he's doing
stand-up but he don't ever post when he
does it like a [ __ ] jackass so nobody
ever knows you like me bro
no i post sometimes i just don't post it
i should post them you sometimes
[ __ ]
honestly i'm starting to realize social
media is important
a little bit 17 years later
17 years later
hey dude this house right here it's like
a house 2 300
let me see this where on hope street
south passing he's literally never
looked bro
two bed one bath two big one bath
perfect 900 square feet bro like come on
dog like how much more do you need
you just told me your dick is the
tiniest thing you've ever seen in your
life
there's bigger ones too
but still i mean the location
oh it's nice
this is nice yeah we'll move in he found
that in like three minutes yeah that was
like that was quick
just send it to tiff out of nowhere i
will text
and then just see what she says random
[ __ ]
you are such a loser what are you gonna
do all right guys that wraps up for this
episode of jesus brain see you guys next
week